So you,
you strike me as like a healthy well-adjusted
creative dad, like relationships. I feel like being a child,
actor breaks, you know,
X percentage of folks, um, you know, let,
let's call it 60% or whatever the number is like, you know, and,
and I'm sure you grew up with people that, um, went through a version of this.
Um, like I became a public figure relatively recently,
but I was already like a dad and like fairly, you know, uh, mature.
So I actually now have a better understanding as to how it messes people up. Um,
and I think you became famous in the time before social media,
so good on you that you didn't have that particular.
Um, but, but would love to hear about your transitions that way,
like going back to school, how did you find Columbia? Cause I,
I went to law school there, so I know the environment somewhat and my,
my wife went there undergrad. Um, so, so, you know, it's like, uh,
so I get some of what that school is about,
but I'm curious about the transition both into college and then out of college
and, and coming back to Hollywood.
Yeah. I mean, a big part of quitting for me and wanting to go to school was,
was getting away from the kind of attention that you get
with quote unquote, fame, fame, something that I've thought about a lot,
because yeah, I've been on,
on TV and in movies and stuff ever since I was young. And, um,
there's an undeniably something very seductive and attractive about it.
Uh it's I think it's pretty deep seated in our biology and it makes sense if
you're out in the wild and you're living in a tribe of animals
and everyone in your tribe knows who you are and has some kind of emotional
attachment to you, you're probably more likely to survive. So that's attractive.
You want that.
And so I think we have just a basic animal attraction to that kind of
attention and fame, um.
To verify what you just said.
I remember I was reading something where it said that if you have primates in
captivity,
they'll actually pay food to see pictures of higher status primates.
Wow. I've not heard that. That's incredible. I want to see that study.
Geez.
Because there was a time when you look up and you're like, Oh,
celebrity culture, like, you know, um, like, uh, not very,
uh, natural, but then when you see that study, you're like, Holy.
Apparently celebrity culture is like the most natural thing in the world.
Of course it's.
Very, very natural, but let's, let's be honest, chimpanzees,
rape and murder each other all day long. But in the world, you know,
there's a lot of things that are natural that we.
Oh yeah. I'm not saying it's a good thing, but it is hardwired into us.
Is it's hardwired into us. And like,
th there's a lot of those things that are hardwired into us, that part of what,
like being a human is about is figuring out like,
how much am I going to be swayed by this,
this primal monkey instinct to, you know,
to act on these urges and that yeah,
there is an urge to, to want to be famous and I've,
I've felt it I'm drawn to it. I, it's something I'd probably struggled with,
to be honest, like on a daily basis, how much does this matter to me?
How much should it sway my decisions, you know? And, uh,
how much can I be happy without it? Uh, it's it's, it's,
it sounds funny to say it's hard because it's a real privilege to have to have
it, but it'll mess people up quick. It really does mess people up. And, uh,
it it's, I w I'm not above saying, like,
it's probably messed me up to some degree.
I do my best to have it not messed me up too much.
I've seen it mess other people up way worse, um, for a lot of reasons.
And it's part of what is actually makes me really concerned about the way that
online culture is moving right now, which is just, and look,
there's something really wonderful about kind of democratizing
fame. I think that in a way that's great fame, like something like that,
shouldn't be limited to just Hollywood and or other, like, you know,
super affluent metropolises throughout the world. It,
it should be like that.
I should be at more accessible to everybody.
And the internet allows for that accessibility,
but what it also does is it,
it brings those kinds of struggles and that kind of addiction
into kinda everyone's life. And,
uh, especially with, with younger people. I, I really cause I, I,
I was going through this when, when I was in junior high, uh,
not because of social media, but because I was in angels in the outfield,
I dealt with like the kind of self doubt and questions of like,
do people really like me for me, or do they like me because I was in this movie.
And how can I know if I'm really worth anything? Or if,
if it's all about these appearances and like, is, is there any media.
All, am I stopped doing these appearances? Like give everyone like, you know,
forget about me, turn on me, et cetera. Exactly.
And so, and, and that was, that made junior high. Like it was,
it made it extra written for me.
And of course junior high is written for everybody for lots of reasons.
But I dunno, I, I am, I, when I see,
especially younger people
experiencing some of the same kind of addiction to fame and attention
that I think like people in Hollywood have experienced for generations.
Now it worries me a bit. It makes me feel like we shouldn't be worried,
you know? Yeah.
Yeah. Like, you're you have teenage kids, like, you know,
having like their entire high school class,
like following them into their bedroom, like, you know,
on their smartphone or whatever. I mean, like, you know,
like that's a very intense experience that yeah.
Self differently,
if you are a performance and there's no boundary there,
then like the most important thing in life, I think,
especially as a younger person,
but it's something I still very much believe in as a dad.
Now you have to have your own,
like your own relationship with
yourself.
You have to have that space where you are you and you know who you are and
you are who you are because of your own preferences and your own
feelings and your own beliefs. And if that goes away,
because you're,
you're constantly offered opportunities to present a
performance version of yourself and get the dopamine hits that you get when
people, you know, hit the heart button and like you, or retweet you or whatever,
it, you it's,
it's easy to lose track of that core
relationship that you have with yourself. It's and it's,
you gotta spend time alone.
You have to spend time just going deep down into yourself
and ignoring what anybody says, because ultimately
as Kurt Cobain says, Oh, we are as all alone or all alone is all we are.
You ultimately, you're the only, you are the only one, everybody out,
no matter how close you get. And like, I feel deeply,
deeply close with like my family, but it's, there, there is no matter what,
there's a difference between that relationship you have inside your own
head and it's precious. And it's,
it's a part of what makes us human and it's loses will it's so
loses will, if you never spend any time on it,
if you spend all your time for others presenting yourself to others.
Wow, man, that's really profound and deep and correct. Uh, you know, I mean,
I've just, I mean, I've just gotten to like a glimpse of it myself. Uh,
I fear for what we're doing to a lot of these kids' brains, um,
and sense of self, uh,
because I certainly never felt that visible and on display when I was a
kid, you know, it's like, I was a shy bookworm and, you know, go home,
close the door and read my fantasy novel or whatever. Yeah. It wasn't like.
But that's important. I did that too. You asked like,
how come I'm like not addicted to drugs or, or, you know, uh,
in jail or something like, unfortunately,
a certain number of kids who experienced fame are,
I think a lot of it is because I was encouraged and did have time to just like
be by myself and read that fantasy novel and,
and like just have that time with myself and not,
not just be always obsessed with what do other people think of me?
How can I present myself to more and more people?
And what should that presentation be? And, um,
it gets convoluted so much with art too. That's the other thing, I, I.
That's a thing about art man. And like,
I I've experienced something like this even. Um, so I'm trying to get universal,
basic income across the finish line.
And one of the things that happened on the campaign trail and like did,
can relate to this, is that like people, uh,
people need a person to like pin it on, you know? So it's like,
if I want this thing to happen, then it's going to have to be me,
like making the case, talking to people saying, Hey, we should really do this.
And there's like, this continued projection outward, you know, that, that like,
that you have to do. And not to say, I'm like,
I'm not like an artist or creative in the same way. But like, I,
there are some parallels because like,
you have to continuously like project this energy out. Uh,
and like, and like, this was the struggle you're describing.
And creativity go hand in hand because like, sometimes you, like,
there are creatives who are like, look, I just like my work to speak for itself.
But unfortunately like does no one operates that way.
Not as much these days. Yeah. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.